[Music]
welcome to deconstructing chatbots I am
Priyanka Vergara and in today's episode
I have a very special guest from
conversation design team at Google Kathy
port Thank You Kathy for being here
thanks so much for having me okay Kathy
so what is conversation design what is
your role at Google so I'm the head of
conversation designed outreach which is
a bit of a mouthful but basically it
means I tell people both inside Google
and outside in the world about
conversation design what it is and why
it's important so what the heck is call
is Asian design at a high level you can
think of it as we're teaching computers
to communicate more like humans and not
the other way around and you know a lot
of us have had frustrating experiences
with our voice assistants I don't know
if you've ever had a frustrating
experience a ton of times how do we
avoid them a lot of times people think
it's a technical problem but in fact
it's often because design best practices
were not followed so we want to make
sure that when people are building these
things if you follow good design
principles you're much more likely to
have a successful experience I am a
developer so I really don't write design
things oh where do I get started
we always recommend you start with
something pretty straightforward called
a sample dialogue it's basically like a
movie script it's a back and forth
between your user and your system and it
really helps you kind of flesh out your
ideas and make sure you're going in the
right direction and you just write these
down and I always tell people don't
worry they really don't have to be
perfect especially right out of the gate
mine are certainly not perfect when I
first write them down but over time you
just remember that old rule there's no
great writing there's only great
rewriting and after you've written some
you do just like you do in Hollywood
with a movie script you do a table read
you read them out loud so you find a
willing victim and then you have them
play the part of the user and you just
take turns reading out loud and you'll
be surprised you'll actually find a lot
of problems and issues with your design
just through that alone before you've
written a single line of code so Kathy I
know how to have a conversation why do I
have to design a conversation before I
started working
I think a lot of people are used to
designing for things like mobile apps or
websites where when somebody taps a
button or swipes or selects a menu item
you know what they chose and if you're
designing a conversational system
whether it's voice or typing people are
gonna say all kinds of things that
you're not going to expect and part of
conversation design is really guiding
people to success by showing them the
types of things that are gonna be able
to say in order for you to be able to
respond okay so I get that I need to
learn more about conversation design but
if I write my prompts correctly then do
you think everything else will just
follow the better you write your prompts
in your flow the more likely you are
gonna get answers you can respond to but
the big thing I always tell people is
when you're working with conversational
experiences people will always say
things you didn't expect and that's just
kind of human I mean when we're talking
we often don't understand every single
word that the other person says but we
don't say oh we had errors that's
because we're so good at what we call
repair we repair our conversations very
gracefully and we get back on track so
that's the kind of strategy you want to
apply to your conversational systems if
you can repair things gracefully when
people say things you don't expect
because that will happen then you can
get them back on track and keep going
can you walk me through some of the
examples of how you would repair a
conversation yeah so if somebody says
things says something your system didn't
expect one quick thing is just to
rephrase the options that are available
at that current time you definitely
don't want to say like I didn't
understand or say that again you're not
helping the person right they're trying
to get through your experience and
you're just you're banding them so one
way is to just sort of rephrase the
current options not the all the things
they can possibly do but just like right
now what should they be focused on
another part of that is called rapid
repro so that's just a really fast way
to do that so let's say you're writing a
chocolate recipe bot and you asked do
you like milk chocolate or dark
chocolate then chocolate and the person
says 65% which you know maybe we don't
understand that so a rapid repro be
sorry was that milk chocolate
chocolate and that'll get people that
contract and one other thing I want to
say about air handling or repair is a
lot of time that first rephrasing or
rapidly prompt will get people right
back on and going again but if they have
a second error right away there's
probably not enough information for them
to know what to do or what to say so at
that point you might want to have
something a little bit longer with a
little more detail like oh your account
number is on the upper left-hand corner
of your bill or something like that
because they're struggling at that point
and you just really want to help them
out okay so whatever understanding is
don't just say I didn't get that right
huh just try to be a little bit more
specific about what was it that you were
expecting and how can the user get back
on track exactly that that's actually
very interesting and amazing advice we
are seeing a lot of smart displays
coming into being what are your
recommendations for designing for those
smart displays yeah I'm really excited
to see some of these different ways that
people can interact and I think smart
displays in particular there's gonna be
a lot of interesting things that people
come up with what we advise is to always
start designing the voice-only
experience first which might seem a
little counterintuitive but in fact the
voice-only experience is often the most
constrained and complex I'll give you an
example let's say you're just writing
about business hours and if you're
thinking about a mobile phone experience
if I'm asking you know what time is
sushi king open you can just pop up a
card on the phone and it has you know
Monday 10:00 to 6:00 Tuesday 11:00 to
7:00 or whatever but if I just ask on a
smart speaker and I say what time is it
open today if you started saying Monday
it's open 6 a.m. to 7 p.m. Tuesday it's
over that's just way too much right so
instead you want to craft the prompt
just like a human would to answer just
the question itself so if I say is it
open right now
that's a yes/no question you should
start with yes or no if I say you know
what time is it open on Wednesday
it opens on Wednesday at 11:00 and
you'll find you might have to write
dozens of prompts to handle that
what would on a mobile phone is only one
card mm-hmm okay what would be some of
your final pieces of advice for our
viewers today
well first I'm just really
decided to see what kind of experiences
you all come up with that are gonna be
really interesting to see I also think
that voice is really matured in the
accessibility realm I think we're
finally seeing examples where voice
technology can really help people who
might have motor impairments or visual
impairments or even cognitive
impairments and I think this just brings
us into the idea of inclusive design
which means we're not just designing for
this person or that person but really
designing for all of us I mean if you
think about it we all have impairments
from time to time situational
impairments like I'm carrying the
groceries in and I can't use my hands or
I forgot my reading glasses and I really
want to read this text message so being
able to use my voice is really handy
there or maybe I fall and break my arm
or something like that so I'm just
excited to see that voice technology is
really risen more to the challenge of
helping people who really need it the
most
yeah thanks Kathy this was awesome I
really learned a lot about conversation
design today thanks for having me
thank you everybody for watching this
show I hope that you guys like to cat
these recommendations and apply some of
those in your conversation designs and
if you would like to learn more go to
action star google.com slash design well
I've been designed the sample dialogue
for this conversation so it doesn't take
two take three
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]